I'm sorry all right
Brianna Brianna where you from
originally where did you grow up um I
was born in uh Beckley West
Virginia I grew up in Beckley I was just
there last week how did you like it well
I've been there many times
um you know there's it seems like they
it has such a terrible drug problem
there yeah probably because there's very
little to do
you once you've gone for a couple walks
in the in the in the forests in the
mountains there's nothing left nothing
left to do no that's why I left Beckley
cuz my um I knew if I didn't I was going
to end up dead at six before I turned
16 when when did you get started with
drugs um I was
eight my
um my mom had gave me heroin and a
needle um because she couldn't pay for
her addiction no more so she sold
me to pay for her habit sold you to her
plug for sex at 8 years
old but I guess that was her way of
trying
to shooting me up with Heroin I guess
was her way of trying to make it to
where I didn't feel anything or feel
pain I'm not
sure
but yeah that went on for how
long um till I was
11 and then I ran
away and
then I was still stayed around
Beckley up until I
was
for 15 getting ready to be
16 and I knew I was I was strong out how
far did you go to school huh how far did
you go to school um I graduated you did
yeah um I was
homebound um I didn't do good in
school
so I got pulled out out well I got
expelled
indefinitely and got homeschooled or
homebound I
graduated I skipped two grades I skipped
third and I
skipped was it Fifth yeah third and
fifth
grade after you graduated what did you
do um still stayed on
drugs you came out here when I came out
here in
California well la
and what is it
2023 let's see 2017
2013 you've been here a long time
yeah what have you been doing since you
been here um up
until like 2 years
ago I was just having fun living
life do you have kids huh do you have
kids yes I have a little girl and twin
boys and then I have twins on the way
you're pregnant now yeah how far long
are you I'm I'm 5 and a half months
pregnant and you're I'm due February
13th and you're using yeah what are you
using F non
Crystal the likelihood is you're going
to lose the kid kids yeah if you're not
clean
yeah where are you staying here on skid
room um I stay between different
places I have a couple friends I stay
with
um I stay at one of my home girls tents
sometimes I'm working my I finally um
got in a program where um with the case
I got a case worker she's she finally
helped me get my birth certificate
social security
card I'm waiting um for my ID to come in
and then she'll be able to uh put me on
the uh what is it Section 8 housing
housing list and um be able to help me
get my Social Security going because I'm
not supposed to be a lot I'm not allowed
to work how how you been making money um
boosting um I used to be a
full-time um I don't know how to say it
escort working girl I do it sometimes
too yeah that's that's a common way to
make money down here yeah I don't like
doing it full time I really don't like
doing it at all I've had a lot of [__]
up incidents
is doing that what kind of stuff have
you
seen um I've been kidnapped I've been
beat I've been
drugged I've been tortured I've been
raped I've been robbed I've been
stabbed I've been held to
gunpoint what does this lifestyle do to
you
emotionally I really don't couldn't tell
you because I a long time ago I blocked
all the my emotions and staying High
Staying High kind of does that for you
too yeah so Hest say I couldn't tell you
what it does to me
emotionally do you have any
friends I have Associates and
acquaintances out here you really can't
have
friends the true definition of
friends these are not friends friends
don't steal from you talk behind your
back do any of that
so do you have regrets in your life of
course I
do yep what's your biggest regret
not staying in my brother's
lives because now that they're older
they want nothing to do with me I have
two brothers one's 23 and one just
turned
18 my 23 old brother got married two
years ago he has a little boy
that's due this
month and he wants nothing to do with
me um he's a
mechanic like I try to talk to
him he shuts me down I finally messaged
or called him and he answered the phone
and I asked him I said well just because
you don't want to see me can you at
least let me see my firstborn nephew and
he's like no I don't even know you why
would I let my child be around somebody
I don't even
know but he really doesn't know me what
do you think people don't understand
about drug
addiction in this
lifestyle
everything
everything it's so like so many people
look down on people who do drugs but
really were just people with problems
that don't know how to cope with it
normally yeah if most people had to deal
with a childhood they being sold for sex
at yeah at what age I was eight
eight they might be more
understanding
but
yeah sorry I'm
crying
thank
you what's been your lowest point in
your life my lowest point in my
life when I got
stabbed and my LP my lungs collapsed and
then a month later
they got infected and I was in ICU on my
deathbed for 11
months because of my lungs got my right
lung got infected due to me being
stabbed they ke I kept on hearing the
nurses and doctors say there's nothing
left we can do there's nothing we can do
left I think we should pull the
plug that's the worst [__] feeling in
the world excuse my
language here and
that do you feel helpless against your
at the time yeah your drug addiction oh
yeah sometimes but then other times it's
like I know I can do it if I just put
forth the effort and try well you have a
reason to do it right now yeah um but in
the past I've
tried and but didn't try to
my full advantage that I know I'm
capable of doing you have three months
before your twins show up
yeah
um what's your biggest
fear them coming out and be being still
born because I've been on drugs and
continue to do
drugs but somebody watching this video
is going to be saying why not just
quit it's not as easy as just
quitting I've been on opiate since I was
eight and I'm
26 it's not just that easy even my
doctor said I have to Wing myself off of
it which is what I'm trying to do
but when you were younger was there
another life that you wanted to to live
was there you had
dreams I wanted to be a forensic
pathologist I wanted to go to school to
be a friend pathologist and until I
became that cuz that's eight um years of
school I wanted to be a
nurse uh that's still to this day
if God allows me that's what I want to
do when I get my life
together how do you think all your Years
of Living on the streets like this has
changed
you honestly if I wouldn't have done
drugs and been out here on the streets
like I have I wouldn't be alive to see
it and come as far as I
have the the the drugs helping you cope
yeah have you seen a
therapist no oh yeah I've seen a
therapist when I was
younger and that didn't go too good I
went in told my therapist I felt like
killing myself and my therapist said
just go ahead and do it say save um our
time save my time and everybody
else's
your therapist said
that yep I will never see a therapist
again because of
that do you have any good memories of
your
life a few not very
many um when my brothers were born when
I
graduated um
School when my babies were
born what would you say is your greatest
strength my greatest
[Music]
strength knowing I can wake up every day
and go through all the [__] I go
through every day with everybody and all
the [__] out here and still keep a
positive attitude still have positive
energy you're
resilient it gets hard sometimes but I
still do it I always every negative
situation I always try to find something
positive out of
it and that's how I keep myself going
and keep
positive I always tell
myself there's people out there that has
it worse than I do do so why complain
why be negative about it how old are you
now Brianna I'm 26 I just turned 26
November
25th two days after Thanksgiving happy
birthday thank
you do you feel like there's anything
that gives your life
meaning it's like you're you're you're
just drifting it
seems my
family
knowing that I have them to a certain
extent do do you talk with your
kids no I don't have custody of them
I've seen them twice their entire life
my twin boys they just turned five and
my little girl she just turned three not
um in
May what would you say to your kids if
you could speak to
them I love you
and I'm sorry I couldn't be more of a
mother to you
guys but I'm glad somebody else has
y'all because I wasn't ready to be a
mother and at least yall have that
Mother and Father Figure in your life to
be there for
you
what what does a typical day in your
life look like what you wake up what do
you
do um what do you even sleep yeah
sleep
sometimes
um the days I do sleep I be asleep a
couple
days but when I wake
up first thing I want to do is get high
of course um so you have to figure out a
way to make money to get
that um normally I won't go to sleep
unless I know for a fact I have
something to wake up
to cuz I know I'm going to be asleep a
couple days so I know when I wake up I'm
going to be
sick dop sick
so
um then I'll go get something to eat or
eat something after I get high
and that's it just depends nor sometimes
I wake up 7 8:00 in the morning
sometimes I'll wake up 2 3 in the
afternoon
um so basically your whole day just
revolves around getting getting high
no
um I like I like to walk I walk around
everywhere I go so um after I get high
eat some
I'll go to the refresh spot take a
shower and then I'll walk for hours at a
time and then I'll come back
downtown
um I'll try to catch a date maybe go
boosting
um see what uh has been going
down been going on since I left earlier
that
day
um see do you think there's a chance
that you you'll spend the rest of your
life down here
no what's going to change that's going
to get you off the
streets when my when I get my Social
Security and I get do get my
housing my sex
and Brian what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life most important lesson I've learned
in my
[Music]
life never underestimate a
person anything is possible right
yeah no matter what a person looks like
does never underestimate a person
because the same person that looks dirty
all strung out [__] up dirty clothes
holes in their clothes their skin black
even though they're might be Mexican
white whatever they could be the same
person to save your
life and that's that's why I say I don't
under
estimate nobody because that's what
happened to me and there the same person
I used to cuss out be rude
to fight for no
reason saved my
life all right Ranna thank you so much
for sharing your story you're welcome I
wish you lots of luck with uh with the
babies and and whatever else you do from
here thank you thank
you